i think i read someplace that more than
half of the
job loss due to online behavior is
because people were trying to be funny
right i mean
not everyone can pull off what tim
dillon
oh and by the way congratulations i
heard that you and just got married yeah
no no we didn't just get married yeah he
proposed let's go got it got it got it
and i said um yes right so some people
can get away oh yeah thank you thank you
sergey has that
has
3 000 likes one of those is mine
uh so for people who are not aware one
of the days in april
tweeted that tim dillon asked me to get
married and i said yes i think tim
uh said the wedding will be on sixth
street in austin bring all of your
weapons which of course is totally
inappropriate this is
this is i i was
i was like uh pg funny and he's goes
rated r uh funny right away but that
said
i mean if there's anyone
i i would like to get married with this
it's that guy and we would do it in
austin and
it would
it would it would be epic it would be
like the uh
the wedding from november rain
um
one of them
mr and mrs oh wow oh mr mister i
apologize wow yeah and you broke and you
broke tradition with the with the jacket
color
you